για να για να καταφέρων ανοιγήσωτοναυτόμο και να έχου έναν λοπόν όπως τούτον οιτ τι
η περίδα κατάτης κατάστασης ο οποίος να μην έρτει μετά που με έγαμε τότα ζηλίκια
που πούκλησεν το κοστάσιο που εκαμε τούτα όλα τα πράγματα και πι ένα σιγνώμη έκαναλάθος
και τον το πράμα που που κάμε εναι μέα γανα τόσεπολύκσμο αλλά ο κόσμος υπασο
προβουμένος είναι άδας και να πω και το χειρότερο να πόέα και το τελευταίω που
τον εξυπνούντων των άνθρωπο από το δύο χικιάδες δεχατρί ως το δύο χικιάδες ήκσι ήταν
γεννικός ελεκτής και τα γεννικός ισαγγελέας ο κόστας οκληρίδης ο οποίος εσυνεργάζοντα στενά ν ανήθελε
μετά εβαενεντα με τος με τους νέους γεννικούς του αναστάσει άι κατάλοιπάν εαν ήθελε μαζί
με τον κληρίδ τούτα ολα που ελάνεν να κάνει εβαλε του ούλος μέσα και για
το ρίκω για τού τον εβαλα μέσα πό τα καταφέρα τότε πούμε το περιβώ των
τροπή αού βέρες το ρίχο τους άλλους ολους γιατό τους αβαρες κυρί και έρκε στ
ι κουρτίζει στον κόσμο και ρκονται μετά ηλάικιστές γιότί τα σοβαρά τα τομα ι σοβαρί
άνθρωποι όπως ος αβας αγγείδες παραμοσχαρν κι έχουμ φερέφονο να υκάλουν πολιτικι είναι τούτος πίαν
έχαμε σελίδα ολόκληι με πίντα χειά εσμελι έχειν ον τω περδίκι τοπως τώρα ε το
φύλαεύθερο τοτη αυτή και λήμέρα πορρού πουρρού πουρρούπουρρούπουρ και ξέστ τι ανθρώπι τ τι ανθρώπι
να ξέρες χτίζουν κάριέρες πα πάσι σε προσωπικότηνες λοιπόν και τ μήνυμα ναφάσει βασικά που
προσπάει α αναπεράσως τον κόσμα εντούτο α ότι δηλαδή πώς γίνετε ας πούμε να λέσε
ότι τούτος άνθρωπο επολέμεισε τη διαυθορά τάξει και φταξαν το ισαγγελίσωεεπον κακή και φτα χρόνια
ήτα με τον καλύτρο ήσαγγελέα κατά την αποψύντου και εξεκινησαν τα διαβατίρα απόότε ξέισαν τα
διαματήρα πιχριστό αυι ποψεκίσα και ο συνεχιστηκα γιατί δεν τα σταμάτησε γιατί δεν έγανε πρόληψη
αφόι πρόλεψη που μετά καιάφηκεα ας ε που νατεγιώσ ότι δενατά χάμε τα διαβατήρια ήταν
μπωτώα τιλεξη να μας κατορούν